hello and welcome to this video plan zim
one okay then Zimbardo yeah that's in
bumper we have a name IAM rockville
makoto junior makoto okay maybe it's the
first i am from Zimbabwe I'm absolutely
without any concrete knowledge am I
don't um yeah chest and Africa something
way I have no idea about i recently read
that chess in Botswana is making
progress somehow and in an article or
something will relate into a linelu me
the wife of irvine let me and she is
very prolific photographer for for chess
event and very often publishes her work
in for on the chest based website and
things like that she meant as mentioned
something like that Chesson what's viola
is making a huge progress okay here
white has lost lots of time went there
with the night quite often the night
will come to a three quicker and here
Knight c3 be 5 a 3 C 2 so it's a huge
huge time loss you okay why does
shooting for before at the moment it's
not working yet and we can actually try
for b5 myself so funny funny move but
interesting
here if I was also moved XD 3 but that
doesn't look doesn't look very
convincing maybe we should have five
threatening a form before I can go back
action if it's not not that great okay
that was the idea so let's let's fire
yeah I played that really badly after
White has lost a million tempe in the
opening I should have at least some kind
of equal position but this is just not
looking any good hmm very badly played
yeah that whole idea with Ruby eight and
so on that was simply awful I never got
in p5 that's the only point of this rook
maneuver okay let's something that I
don't mind be taking on c5 was I mean
looked more dangerous to me this is not
such a big issue I hope as now as now I
can go d3 here as now v6 is not so weak
in comparison to after after the capture
md3 I can play em winning the exchange
but this is a pretty pretty fishy way to
win the exchange I think I'd rather want
to trade the light squared Bishop EF
possible that's straight
it also allows me to play route 88 and
the post them on them on the 8th file ok
so here taking only seven I don't mind
much I have some some plain out here on
the D to pollen c4 pawn if you get the
night to d5 I'll just sacrifice I don't
mind that ok let's let's prevent it
though check
f-for cheeks look at seven stud maybe
like this going for f4 difficult to
prevent well it looks okay it should be
okay hmm yeah maybe that was maybe it
was necessary if it was necessary that
I'm taking jack that's made that's made
me tonight resigns yeah that it was a
pretty bad position but I think he
probably made a couple of inaccurate
moves at least he it feels like I'm
worse if he just takes you five I think
I'm just worse yeah I have to either
give the pawn immediately or take on d3
and if i take on d3 is this and now a
normal fruit lee one or so here I'm
worse because I cannot easily increase
pressure on this pawn where this pawn
looks weak and he's got the two bishops
the bishop on g7 is also not good here I
widest bad i'm quite a lot better and
this is the reason why i didn't like my
i will play him after this i'm ok again
SB six is not easily um yeah put under
pressure and here i think i'm i'm ok he
can play Bishop e7 here but i don't
think that this is something that
threatens me much as especially the
light squared Bishop i can just play a
move here and let
take with the light squares this is not
not such a big issue it's still not
clear anything about let's say what does
the engine give f6 with equal play from
interesting just this and compensation
it's also the weakness on c4 very sharp
position energy he didn't do much at all
you know this is this is comfortable for
black of it shouldn't be that quick wind
f-4s hmm maybe here maybe it was if this
is necessary white has a problem but the
computer wants to go rookie to a 1 f
four and twenty one I computer is very
relaxed in this kind of position the the
human would be like scared of things
like that it's not working due to Luke a
seven but I move like that would scare a
human player but ok something like this
is supposedly equal according to the
engine German okay after this White's
life isn't easy but 95 is just just
blundering the game away tough position
really tough I think if he takes you
five I have trouble and deservedly after
my my dad play him the drew crook b8
it's just not a good idea I think he I
should just play a normal move Bishop f5
or whatever just develop a piece we
cannot play before easily or here I
should go be five now this is the thing
that would make some sense out of my
play at least like this back
83 there should be six this it's kind of
interesting even though huh yeah it's
not not a good idea that would be a move
okay well thanks for watching